Trascrizione: Vincenzina Lopalco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno, ciao a tutti.
Allora, prima di tutto parto
dicendo che è un grande piacere essere qui
a Mirandola, il nostro territorio,
e anche di comunicarvi,
di farvi partecipi del fatto
che facciamo parte di uno dei territori
più importanti a livello mondiale,
la Motor Valley.
in questi giorni a Modena
c'è una manifestazione importantissima;
e questo ci deve rendere fieri,
perché in giro per il mondo
la Motor Valley è paragonabile,
anche se con una magnitudo
un pochino inferiore,
a quella che è la Silicon Valley.
In ogni parte del mondo
dove si va, dove noi andiamo,
ci chiedono come è possibile
che in un lembo di terra
come l'Emilia Romagna, veramente piccolo,
ci possa essere così tante aziende
che fanno le più belle
vetture supersportive al mondo;
e questo è una delle domande
a cui è difficile anche rispondere.
Diciamo sempre che, probabilmente,
è perché qui c'è un tessuto sociale,
c'è una conoscenza, c'è una passione
che non c'è da nessun'altra parte;
e questo non è solo parte
di chi fa vetture,
ma di tutto quello che è il terziario,
quelli che fanno tantissime attività;
e anche in questa regione,
in questo lembo di terra
abbiamo eccellenze che sicuramente
sono riconosciute a livello mondiale.
Ma partiamo da che cosa siamo.
Noi siamo nati, l'azienda
che io rappresento
è nata dalla discussione
di due imprenditori della zona
dove il loro antagonismo sul prodotto
ha fatto sì di generare quella
che è diventata poi la Lamborghini:
un'azienda che produce vetture
e che è nata veramente sulla discussione
di chi era più bravo a fare una cosa
a giudicarne un'altra.
In questa piccola clip vi voglio
solo dare un piccolo excursus
di come è nata l'azienda,
di come si è evoluta dagli anni '60
e quello che poi noi abbiamo preso
in essere e in carico.
(Video)
Oggi cosa è importante dire?
È importante dire che noi veniamo
da oltre 50 anni di innovazione.
Cosa significa innovazione?
Abbiamo sempre lavorato su dei modelli
rendendoli più veloci,
più potenti, più leggeri,
che hanno dato sempre tantissime emozioni
ma rimanendo in un percorso evolutivo,
quindi di non cambiamenti epocali.
E questo sicuramente è un qualche cosa
che non voglio dire ci ha facilitato,
perché è sempre difficile,
ma ci ha dato un percorso ben definito
su come andarci a muovere.
Oggi,
con quello che sta succedendo
nel mondo, se ne parlava prima,
la CO2 sta diventando
un problema a livello mondiale.
La CO2, per dare la definizione
che ogni tanto ne diamo
proprio per rendere partecipi tutti
di cosa significa,
è il termometro che ci dice
quanto il mondo si sta riscaldando.
Quindi più aumenta la CO2,
più il mondo si riscalda.
Questo è un fenomeno fisico dimostrato,
e quindi tutto il mondo sta chiedendo
di ridurre le emissioni di CO2.
Per fare questo è chiaro
che non si può continuare
a evolvere il prodotto:
occorre veramente fare una rivoluzione.
E fare una rivoluzione
è una cosa difficilissima:
a livello industriale,
significa cambiare tanti dei paradigmi
che sono parte della nostra conoscenza.
Però questo è quello che ci aspetta,
ed è quello che dobbiamo affrontare.
Perché è importante una rivoluzione?
Perché noi siamo persone
che sono abituati,
siamo tutti nati andando
alla pompa di benzina,
facendo rifornimento,
caricando combustibile;
in tre-quattro minuti
avevamo il pieno in macchina,
lo trovavamo ovunque,
in ogni singolo piccolo paese
c'era una, due pompe di benzina.
Ci aspetta un qualche cosa
che sicuramente si muoverà
nell'elettrificazione.
L'elettrificazione però è una forma
di stoccaggio dell'energia
che è sicuramente
un attimino più complessa.
È più difficile trovare
delle colonnine di ricarica.
Quando si va a ricaricare una benzina,
chi ha già avuto l'esperienza
di fare la ricarica
di un veicolo elettrico,
occorrono, se la colonnina
è veloce, 30-40 minuti;
e noi sappiamo tutti che al giorno d'oggi
il tempo è uno dei beni più importanti.
È l'unica cosa che non possiamo comprare.
Quindi sicuramente è una rivoluzione,
ma dobbiamo approcciarla
nel modo più corretto.
In una super sportiva -
e il mio mestiere è progettare
super sportive -
qual è la grande sfida?
È che le batterie contengono
rame, piombo, elementi pesantissimi.
Il peso è il nemico delle supersportive,
è quello che cerchiamo di vincere
usando materiali superprestazionali,
leggeri e quant'altro.
In più le batterie, purtroppo,
hanno una forma molto regolare.
Sono dei gran parallelepipedi
che tante volte rischiano di condizionare
quello che è il design di una macchina,
quello che è la bellezza di un veicolo,
per cui è un qualche cosa che ci assegna
un compito molto difficile da risolvere.
Per fare questo,
questa è una delle immagini
che mi piace di più,
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare
sempre in un modo diverso.
Il coltellino svizzero
è quello che ci fa percepire
come in un oggetto solo
si possano mettere dentro tante funzioni
salvando peso,
salvando quello
che noi chiamiamo packaging
ed avendo idee brillanti
sul come approcciare
un problema da risolvere.
Oggi la meccanica è fatta di trasmissione.
Penso tutti sappiate
che da un motore esce un albero
che poi va a comandare
le ruote, le fa girare.
Sono pezzi d'acciaio pesantissimi.
Se pensiamo all'elettrificazione,
dobbiamo reimmmaginarci il fatto
di portare l'energia con dei cavi
anziché con dei cilindri d'acciaio,
quindi in che modo
possiamo trovare delle soluzioni
che ci permettano di alleggerire
e di essere ancora più flessibili
per poter risolvere
uno dei problemi più annosi.
Però c'è una condizione
che è fondamentale.
Noi facciamo macchine, vendiamo macchine;
e siamo desiderati da tutti,
perché regaliamo emozioni.
Se non saremo in grado
di regalare emozioni nel futuro,
brand come il nostro non esisteranno più.
E l'emozione è un qualche cosa
che è fatta di sensorialità,
è fatta di rispetto di accelerazioni,
frenate, rumore, suono;
e questo è una delle cose, purtroppo,
che non dico è nemica
dell'elettrificazione,
ma è una delle cose più difficili
che noi dobbiamo combattere,
ed essere in grado di risolvere.
Se l'emozione è la cosa che dobbiamo
di sicuro salvaguardare,
c'è questa frase di Tomasi
di Lampedusa, ne"Il Gattopardo",
che secondo me descrive quella che è
la grande sfida che ci attende:
"Se vogliamo che tutto rimanga com'era",
quindi le stesse emozioni di prima,
"occorre che tutto cambi",
bisogna cambiare tutti i paradigmi
dell'automobile supersportiva.
In che modo?
Occorre approcciarli in un modo diverso,
bisogna tornare nelle scuole.
Perché nelle scuole?
Perché nelle scuole gli studenti
hanno una capacità di vedere il futuro
completamente diverso dal nostro.
Per questo noi abbiamo
aperto collaborazioni con l'MIT a Boston,
abbiamo aperto laboratori,
abbiamo collaborazioni con Stanford
come li abbiamo con le università
più importanti italiane:
il Politecnico di Milano, Torino,
l'Università di Bologna.
In tutto il mondo, andiamo a cercare
questo tipo di competenza.
Occorre collaborare con settori
che non facciano parte del nostro mondo,
ma abbiano approcci completamente diversi
nel risolvere problematiche tecniche.
L'esempio della Boeing,
con cui abbiamo aperto
diversi rapporti di collaborazione,
è fondamentale:
materiali leggeri, soluzioni innovative.
Ma anche con aziende che non hanno
nulla a che fare con l'automobile;
la Callaway fa mazze da golf.
Però in questo contesto
si sono trovate soluzioni
che riportano il suono,
riportano la leggerezza,
riportano al trattamento di materiali
che non avremmo mai pensato
si potessero fare.
E poi bisogna tornare
nelle nuove generazioni.
Perché le nuove generazioni?
Perché, purtroppo, chi ha la mia età
tende sempre a dire:
"Abbiamo sempre fatto così,
perché devo fare in un modo diverso? ".
I giovani sono dei provocatori,
i giovani sono quelli
che non hanno una memoria storica
che li obbliga a fare cose
come le facciamo noi;
e l'esempio che faccio sempre
è l'ingegner Dallara,
che probabilmente tutti conoscete,
il primo direttore tecnico di Lamborghini.
Fu direttore tecnico
di Lamborghini a 26 anni
quando disegnò la Miura.
Era un bambino,
se lo consideriamo con l'attitudine
che c'è oggi nel misurare l'età.
Questo è importante.
Per cui, in che modo
noi approcciamo il futuro?
Abbiamo reinventato il modo
di fare lo storage dell'energia
usando i telai e le monoscocche;
abbiamo sviluppato soluzioni elettriche
di powertrain completamente nuove
mettendo i motori nelle ruote;
e stiamo reinventando il suono
di un veicolo elettrico:
un suono che sia naturale,
che sia all'altezza di quello che vogliamo
e ci immaginiamo che possa dare
le stesse emozioni di cui
abbiamo parlato prima.
In tutto questo noi ci stiamo preparando,
noi riteniamo di essere pronti;
e quello che è importante
è che siate anche pronti voi
per sfidare questo nuovo futuro
che ci porterà ad avere
una sostenibilità sicuramente migliore
dando le emozioni che un marchio
come il nostro deve poter dare.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)